well they continue to call for a DHS
secretary Miami of course to resign or
face impeachment so what does my next
guest think Lieutenant Chris Oliveira is
from the Texas Department of Public
Safety uh what what is the thinking down
there I mean it's it was a pretty
powerful uh statement from Minority 11
leader McCarthy who will be Majority
Leader real soon
will that go a long way in your mind
toward maybe getting some real
resolution or something out of this
Administration
well that's what we're hoping for
Charles and also speaking with border
patrol agents in the field that's what
they're hoping for as well but there
needs to be accountability as far as why
the federal government has allowed this
crisis to get out of hand I mean we've
seen the policies that we're working
prior to 2021 there's no there's no
disputing that we know that we know for
a fact the numbers were at record low as
far as apprehensions uh encounters as
far as arrests and enforcement action
was at an all-time high because agents
and I say just were able to do their job
and actually enforce uh federal law and
that's by arresting some of these legal
immigrants that are coming across our
borders but that's not being done and
that's why we're seeing this Mass
migration taking place we're seeing
human smuggling
um that's that's unprecedented levels
right now where these human smokers and
smart organizations in Mexico are
involved in a multi-billion dollar
industry it's about Thai uh criminal
Network that they're seeing right now
that's because of this whole situation
on the border but there needs to be
accountability and the question needs to
be answered is why are they allowing
this to take place why aren't they
following the policies that were working
as I mentioned part of 2021 one because
it did stand the flow of mass migration
and ironically that's one of the Crux of
the issue for for Kevin McCarthy that he
brought up in that press conference is
that the administration particularly the
head of DHS continues to tell the public
everything is either A-Okay there's not
a crisis or B if there's anything wrong
with it it was from the prior
Administration but you're saying things
were going much better than uh then and
what I'm wondering is when folks who are
thinking about illegally entering this
country when they hear from the
administration downplaying all of this
is that seeing to them as a red carpet
come on in we're not going to say
anything we're going to look the other
way we're going to downplay all of it
that's exactly what it is and that's why
we're seeing record numbers I mean just
right now Charles for this fiscal year
which started on October 1st I mean
we're already on record Pace with over
349 000 encounters and over 134 000
known dataways which was reported by
grip Jenkins I mean we're already on
record Pace to surpassed last year's
numbers and we just started so it is
essentially a red carpet a welcome red
carpet to these uh immigrants that are
coming across and that's why they
continue coming I mean we're not seeing
any consequences we hear about
consequences but yet nothing's being
done there's no strategies in place to
stand the flow of mass migration and we
know for a fact that the border is not
secured because we see it firsthand I've
been out here all this week you know
during the Thanksgiving break with our
Troopers with our border patrol agent
seeing firsthand what they're dealing
with having to chase down these illegal
immigrants and avoiding capture involved
in high-speed chases of human Smugglers
I mean it's a never-ending situation
when all these agents and our Troopers
are having to deal with and it all stems
from the fact that there's no policies
in place to stop this little Mass
migration and something needs to be done
because right now this is unacceptable
able and it's not it's not going to be
sustainable any much longer yeah I was
just reading a story uh from just
exactly a week ago of a New Yorker uh
who took uh your uh you guys on a
high-speed trades uh Chase ended up
having four illegal uh immigrants on
board what about uh 2.3 million it's a
it's hard number to comprehend right I
mean any country would say this is a
problem it's just you got to control
your borders but what happens when title
42 goes away
I mean I'm here who's going to get
exponentially worse
well it is I mean we're right now you
know daily average that we're seeing is
all seven eight thousand a day daily
encounters on our Southern border so you
can just kind of put that in perspective
you know we're title four that's what
title 42 in place so one side of 42 is
gone I mean we can expect anywhere from
double to Triple the numbers that we're
seeing
um on a daily basis and with that and
we're not just talking about those that
are surrendering to law enforcement that
are seeking Asylum we're also including
those that are trying to avoid capture
we're going to see an increase in those
illegal immigrants that are trying to
avoid capture and circumvent checkpoints
and also with human smuggling so it's
going to be a consistent uh situation
Charles that's going to be out of
control and that's the only thing that
we actually had in place that was
actually sustaining the situation
somewhat right but now we got to see
what we can put in place to try to stem
that flow and go off these organizations
that are that are exploiting the
situation right now you know let me ask
you also about the Texas governor Greg
Abbott sending Armored Transport
vehicles to the Border this week after
of course declaring that there's an
invasion going on and of course a lot of
pushback on that folks saying it's a
inhumane but is there do you believe
that there is a real need and necessity
for this
well Charles we know for a fact without
a doubt that Governor Abbott is doing by
far more than any other governor in
terms of border security and the fact
that we're deploying an additional you
know armored vehicles to the Border it
is essential it is needed I mean these
vehicles are deterrent I mean they act
as a deterrent from these current
organizations because when they see
National Guard On the Border they see
armored vehicles those Runners the ones
we talk about the gotaways they're not
going to cross in those areas so it's
very important to have those you know
those National Guardsmen armored
vehicles on those areas where we don't
have a border wall That's why again
going back to the border wall that's why
it's very important to have some type of
infrastructure in place so you can close
those gaps but without that you have to
use you know Manpower which is National
Guard Troopers border patrol or armored
vehicles in this case yeah very
essential to border security I was in
the security police in the Air Force and
I the first thing I learned we worked at
Sac bases right nuclear weapons first
thing we learned was deterrence is the
biggest thing as you just mentioned
exactly Lieutenant oliveiras thank you
very much appreciate you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else